wir gucken noch mal ein bisschen auf die
Geschichte Hartz IV vor fast 20 Jahren
verabschiedet 2003 war es 2005 ist es
dann in Kraft getreten und das war eine
Zerreißprobe eine Durststrecke danach
für die SPD die immer wieder gemessen
wurde an diesen Maßnahmen an der
Zusammenlegung von Arbeitslosen und
Sozialhilfe dann 2019 gab es das erste
die das erste Papier dieses wie es bei
der SPD immer hieß Hartz IV zu
überwinden ein bürgergeldkonzept von der
damaligen Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Andrea Nahles
bekämpft wurde Hartz IV massive von der
Linken die dadurch viel Gewinn gesogen
hat irgendwie auch was auch einer der
gründungsgründe gewesen ist für die
Zusammenlegung von wer oder das fürs
Zusammengehen von whsg und
Linkspartei.PDS und jetzt sind wir so
weit fast 20 Jahre nach der
Verabschiedung das tatsächlich die erste
Beratung stattfindet zum Bürgergeld und
wir werden gleich eine Debatte hören die
uns 90 Minuten lang ist wir haben 15
Minuten Zeit um schon mal auf ein paar
Kernpunkte zu gucken und ich freue mich
dass heute morgen bei uns sind Jessica
tatti aus der Linksfraktion wo sie
Arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitische
Sprecherin ist und Martin Rosemann ist
bei uns aus der SPD-Fraktion Sprecher
für Arbeit und Soziales ganz witzig
haben wir im Vorfeld nicht gewusst ihre
Wahlkreise liegen gerade mal zehn
Kilometer auseinander etwas mehr
vielleicht immerhin so daher kennen sie
sich unter anderem deshalb ja auch ganz
gut ich fange mal bei Herrn Rosemann an
das Bürgergeld so heißt es im
Koalitionsvertrag soll die Würde der
oder des Einzelnen achten das lässt den
Umkehrschluss zu dass das bei ALG2 bei
Hartz IV nicht der Fall gewesen ist
zumindest hatten viele den Eindruck vor
allem solche Leute die sich angestrengt
haben die sich bemüht haben und trotzdem
mit der
sanktionseindrohung konfrontiert worden
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir auf
der einen Seite Mitwirkungspflichten
beibehalten und auch Leute die sich
verweigern dieser Mitwirkung auch
weiterhin mit Sanktionen rechnen müssen
aber dass wir diejenigen die sich
wirklich anstrengen und bemühen und
mitwirken dass die nicht ständig mit der
sanktionskeule bedroht werden das heißt
aber doch Hartz IV dann unterm Strich
etwas grenzwertig aus heutiger Sicht und
was die Würde des Einzelnen eingehen
es sind im Laufe der Jahre Fehler
gemacht worden auch bei dieser Reform
aber ich glaube wichtig ist vor allem
den Blick nach vorne zu richten denn wir
haben heute eine völlig andere
Arbeitsmarktlage als noch im Jahr 2003
oder 2005 wir hatten damals
Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute haben wir
Arbeitskräftemangel und deswegen müssen
wir die Instrumente der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik auf die Höhe der
Zeit bringen und das machen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld gucken wir auf einige Punkte
aus diesem Gesetzentwurf gleich noch mal
detailliert Frau tatti ich habe es eben
auch schon angesprochen Hartz IV ALG2
war einer der gründungsgründe für den
Zusammenschluss von whsg und Linkspartei
geht den jetzt einer dieser
gründungsgründe auf Dauer verloren nein
das denke ich nicht weil wir haben jetzt
das zwölfte Änderungsgesetz von Hartz IV
und ich erkenne durchaus anders mit
diesem Gesetz erstmals auch einige
Verbesserungen auf den Weg gebracht
werden aber es ist aus meiner Sicht
keine Überwindung von Hartz IV wie das
ja seitens der
Regierungskoalition sowieso eine
Monstranz vor sich hergetragen wird wir
haben Euro Anpassung das ist aus meiner
Sicht keine echte Regelsatzerhöhung es
ist ja maximal ein Inflationsausgleich
der sowieso hätte kommen müssen laut
Verfassungsgericht also von daher kann
da von einer echten Erhöhung keine Rede
sein wir haben die Situation das
Hartz-IV-Empfänger auch heute am
wenigsten an Weiterbildungen teilnehmen
daran wird auch nichts geändert im
Gegenteil es wird werden ja noch mehrere
also 600 9 Millionen Euro im
Eingliederungstitel eingespart das
betrifft auch den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
der gerade für diejenigen die sonst
keine Arbeit finden können ein sehr
wichtiges Instrument ist also da wird
kaputt gespart und deshalb kann ich
nicht so ganz erkennen wo jetzt diese
wirkliche Abkehr von Hartz IV sein soll
guck mal was Martin Rosemann gleich dazu
sagte ich mir wollte tatsächlich mit dem
Regelsatz auch anfangen bei der
Betrachtung einzelner Punkte die Grünen
haben im Koalitionsvertrag oder im
Vorfeld dieses Gesetzentwurfs 100 Euro
mehr gewollt der Chef des Paritätischen
Wohlfahrtsverbandes Gesam
innerhalb von 200 gesprochen warum
reichen ihrer Meinung nach 50 Euro
Erhöhung aus für den Einzelnen
wir decken damit die massive
Preissteigerung ab die jetzt in den
letzten Monaten auch auf die
grundsicherungshaushalte zugekommen sind
und das ist ja zunächst mal wichtig wir
müssen schauen dass jetzt niemand
angesichts dieser Preissteigerungen
unter die Räder kommt das gilt für
Menschen mit geringen Löhnen und es gilt
für Menschen in der Grundsicherung und
da sind diese 50 Euro angemessen ich
glaube die 50 Euro sind schon
beschlossen worden vor diesem
eigentlichen inflationsgeschehen was ich
seit dem monatlichen ereigneter
Entlastungspaket beschlossen worden es
gab vorher keine Einigung in der
Koalition auf eine grundsätzliche
Regelsatzerhöhung der stand vorher war
dass der bisherige Mechanismus
weitergeht es wären ungefähr 20 Euro
gewesen
was halten Sie für nötig ja also es ist
wie gesagt die Leute bleiben so arm wie
vorher weil es eben maximal die
Preissteigerungen
ausgleicht und wir haben ja die
Situation dass die Leute standen ja
schon vor der kasseninflation mit dem
Rücken zur Wand finanziell und deshalb
sagt die Linke auch wir brauchen eine
Neuberechnung der Regelsätze und bis
dahin eben
200 Euro mehr im Monat damit auch
wirklich dass es wirklich den Leuten
auch finanziell besser geht und sie auch
den Kopf frei haben sich auf ihre
Arbeitsplatzsuche eine Weiterbildung
oder eine sonstige berufliche
Neuausrichtung vorzubereiten die ganze
Erhöhung wird jetzt schon erheblich
teurer als ursprünglich mal geplant war
wie würden Sie diese 200 Euro mehr denn
finanzieren wollen naja also ich meine
wir haben ja geht eine Regierung die
sagt es gibt mehr Beratung ist es gibt
mehr würde mehr Respekt und so weiter
und wir sehen das kaputt gespart wird
also es kann ja keine Rede davon sein
das müssen wir glaube ich mal ein
bisschen konkretisieren was sie mit
kaputt gespart eigentlich meinen also
wir haben die Situation dass die
Jobcenter in diesem Haushalt 2023 eine
Milliarde weniger zur Verfügung haben
als sie brauchen ich weiß nicht wie sie
damit eine Beratung auf Augenhöhe
umsetzen können sollen wenn diese
Milliarde fehlt sie werden in die
eingliederungsmittel greifen müssen dass
der einzige Weg für die Jobcenter dann
ihre Verwaltung ihr Personal und so
weiter zu sichern und zusätzlich wird er
bei den eingliederungsmitteln selber
gespart bei Weiterbildungen beim
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt Minister Heil
hatte 150.000
Jobs im sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
versprochen in der letzten Legislatur
wir sind jetzt bei 40.000 das wird
weiter sinken und deshalb werden wir
auch noch mal einen Antrag einbringen
diese 150.000 zu finanzieren weil wir
denken dass es notwendig ist das Hartz
IV Empfänger auch eine Chance bekommen
wieder in Arbeit zu kommen er hat Frau
Tati Recht der Rosemann
nein vor allem hat sie jetzt nichts dazu
gesagt wie sie 200 Euro mehr Regelsatz
finanzieren will und ich finde es schon
ganz interessant ich meine die Kritik
kommt jetzt von links es sei nicht genug
es sei zu wenig und die kritik kommt von
rechts wir würden das Lohnabstandsgebot
nicht einhalten und es würde sich nicht
mehr lohnen zu arbeiten was auch Unsinn
ist weil wir gleichzeitig zum ersten
Oktober den Mindestlohn auf 12 € erhöht
haben aber ich finde mal interessant
wenn man mit dieser Kritik von links und
mit rechts umgeht dann haben wir glaube
ich ziemlich viel an der Stelle richtig
gemacht und im Übrigen geht es ja bei
den Bürgergeld nicht nur um den
Regelsatz sondern es geht in der Tat
darum eine neue Kultur in den Jobcentern
zu leben es geht darum auf Augenhöhe zu
unterstützen es geht darum auch sehr
viel mehr auf nachhaltige Integration in
Arbeit zu setzen und deswegen ist es
falsch was Frau hat die gesagt hat zum
Thema Weiterbildung wir schaffen den
sogenannten vermittlungsvorgang ab der
bisher gesagt hat egal in Beschäftigung
das hat Vorrang vor Weiterbildung das
schaffen wir ab weil wir die Erfahrung
gemacht haben dass wir damit zu wenig
nachhaltige Investitionen bekommen aber
das ist ja der eigentliche Vorwurf den
Frau Tatje macht dass sie nämlich sagt
dass sie das was sie jetzt gerade
beschreiben die Jobcenter gar nicht
leisten können weil da gespart worden
ist
oder was Frau Tati verschweigt ist dass
die Aufstellung des Bundeshaushalts zu
einem Zeitpunkt passiert ist als das
bürgergeldgesetz noch gar nicht vorlag
das heißt der Bundeshaushalt
berücksichtigt das Bürgergeld noch gar
nicht und deswegen kann ich Frau Tati
beruhigen wir werden im
parlamentarischen Verfahren die
notwendigen Mittel für die Umsetzung des
Bürgergeldes bereitstellen als Koalition
Gegenrecht ist überhaupt nicht weil wenn
man doch weiß dass man das Bürgergeld
als Überwindung von Hartz IV wenn man
das vorgibt Hartz IV überwinden zu
wollen dann kürzt man doch nicht bei den
Jobcentern und dann kürzt man auch nicht
bei den eingliederungsmitteln wenn man
das ernsthaft vorhat und deshalb bleibe
ich dabei immer das heißt das was die
Koalition ja gesagt hat dass sie Hartz
IV überwinden will sie wie gesagt wir
machen den zwölftes Änderungsgesetz
sondern sie haben gesagt sie überwinden
Hartz IV und das wird da mit diesem
Gesetz so wie es im Moment vorliegt
nicht passieren sondern das Bürgergeld
bleibt Hartz IV Rosemann ja das ist
schlicht falsch also wir sind noch mal
sagen wir haben den Haushalt aufgestellt
da gab es noch kein bürgergeldgesetz und
das sind die parlamentarischen Abläufe
die könnte auch ratati kennen und
deswegen ist es so dass wir die dass wir
die Aufgaben des Bürgergeldes die werden
wir finanzieren das in den
parlamentarischen Beratungen
sicherstellen den Haushalt Frau Tati
macht am Ende der Deutsche Bundestag und
nicht die Bundesregierung dafür gibt es
ein Verfahren das ist völlig Klarinette
gegangen die Jobcenter so auf ausstatten
dass sie das Bürgergeld auch umsetzen ob
ihnen das gefällt oder nicht und ihre
ganze
oppositionsargumentation wird dann in
sich an der Stelle zusammenbrechen und
ich will es noch mal deutlich sagen
entscheidend mit diesem Bürgergeld ist
der Kulturwandel das ist eine
Unterstützung gibt auf Augenhöhe das
sanktionsandrohung nur noch für
diejenigen erfolgen die sich verweigern
und nicht mehr für die die mitwirken
dass es einen kooperationsplan gibt der
gemeinsam auf Augenhöhe vereinbart wird
wo die
Fähigkeiten die Interessen der
Leistungsberechtigten berücksichtigt
werden und dass wir sehr viel mehr auf
eine nachhaltige Integration durch
Weiterbildung setzen als das der Fall
war das ist die größte Sozialreform seit
vielen Jahren und das ist ein
Paradigmenwechsel und deswegen
lassen wir Hartz IV mit dieser Reform
hinter uns das mit dem Haushalt Frau
Tati wird sich in den kommenden Wochen
erst entscheiden in der Tat ich glaube
da wird kann auch einiges nachgelegt
werden da wird so einige Probleme geben
die die Koalition dann noch bekommt weil
einfach ja auch die Steuereinnahmen doch
deutlich niedriger sein werden als man
das nicht ursprünglich mal vorgestellt
hat und alles jetzt hier natürlich durch
die Krise insgesamt und die Rezession
die sich andeutet ausgelöst es war von
hier von würde die Rede von Augen Höhe
einen Schlagwort was immer eine große
Rolle gespielt hat bei ALG2 und bei
Hartz IV war das Thema Sanktionen sehen
sie da Frau Tati die Koalition mit ihrem
Gesetzentwurf den sie heute das erste
mal hier ins Parlament einbringt auf
einem richtigen Weg nein natürlich ist
es ein richtiger Weg weil jetzt maximal
noch 30 Prozent Sanktionen möglich sind
das war jetzt aber auch jetzt nicht eine
glorreiche Idee der Koalition sondern
ist die Umsetzung des
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil dass die
Sanktion ja teilweise für
verfassungsgebietig erklärt hat das war
2019 jetzt wird darauf auch gesetzlich
reagiert aber natürlich bleibt die Linke
auch da dabei das sozusagen dann eine
nachhaltige Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt ein Arbeitsplatz mit dem
man seine finanzielle Situation wirklich
verbessern kann der beste Anreiz bleibt
für Arbeit und nicht die Sanktion und
dafür muss man auch prekäre Arbeit
bekämpfen ein Punkt wo sie beide
mutmaßlich einiger sind als bei den
bisherigen Punkten die wir besprochen
haben die Reaktionen aus der und
insbesondere auch aus der Unionsfraktion
da heißt es dann der des Bürgergeld so
wie es geplant ist jetzt von der
Koalition motiviere nicht zur
Arbeitssuche verringert den Abstand
zwischen bürgergeldempfänger und den
unteren Lohngruppen was er wieder sie
daher Rose man ja das stimmt schlichtig
weil wir den Mindestlohn zum ersten
Oktober auf 12 Euro erhöht haben
übrigens die CDU hat ja da nicht
mitgemacht sondern das haben wir gemacht
das Ampelkoalition maßgeblich die SPD
das war eines der zentralen Versprechen
von Olaf Scholz im Wahlkampf das haben
wir umgesetzt und damit bleibt
finanzielle Anreiz bestehen wir
verbessern sogar die
hinzuverdienstregelungen im neuen
Bürgergeld in dem ersten Schritt schon
mal wir werden das auch noch mal tiefer
gehende anpacken aber wir machen da
schon mal einen ersten Schritt wer
entlasten jetzt Geringverdiener bei den
Sozialabgaben indem wir die
midijobzone bis 2000 Euro ausweiten also
ich kann diese Kritik nicht
nachvollziehen und ich halte sowieso für
ziemlich daneben jetzt die Ärmsten gegen
noch ärmer auszuspielen diese Spaltung
der Gesellschaft die hilft nun wirklich
nicht und das Bürgergeld wird
Mitwirkungspflichten vorsehen aber in
einem vernünftigen Rahmen und in dem
Rahmen den es Bundesverfassungsgericht
uns vorgegeben hat und wichtig ist dass
wir die Spreu vom Weizen trennen
diejenigen die sich bemühen die sich
anstrengen die mitwirken nicht mit
Sanktionen bedrohen und diejenigen die
sich verweigern ist sicherlich auch gibt
oder die sich durch Schwarzarbeit
entziehen dass die weiterhin auch mit
Sanktionen Bedrohungen diejenigen die
vielleicht nicht können weil sie
psychisch krank sind identifizieren und
die dann eben auch nicht in die
sektionsspirale reindrücken sondern den
zielgenau helfen das ist das der Gedanke
des Bürgergeldes ich glaube das ist
genau das was das Gerechtigkeitsgefühl
den Menschen auch entspricht und was
auch den einzelnen gerecht wird sie
haben frei hatte in einer Pressemeldung
zum Bürgergeld zu diesem Gesetzentwurf
von Licht und Schatten gesprochen der
Punkt in der Rosemann eben angesprochen
hat fällt er eher unter Licht oder eher
untersch naja also erstmal finde ich es
ein bisschen zweifelhafte man auf der
einen Seite sagte dass man da nicht
irgendwie Spaltung herbei reden darf
aber dann sagt man will die Spreu vom
Weizen trennen also muss ja auch noch
mal daran erinnern dass hartz1-4 eben
eine Reform des Arbeitsmarktes war eine
Prekarisierung des Arbeitsmarkts mit
ganz vielen
niedriglohnensektor mit ganz viel
prekäre Beschäftigung wie
leiharbeitssachgrundloser Befristung
Minijobs ist ja jetzt auch noch mal
ausgedehnt worden die minijob-grenze so
dass eben gerade Menschen die in Hartz
IV sind wenn sie eine Arbeit aufnehmen
oftmals noch abhängig bleiben von der
Hartz IV Leistung weil sie eben dann in
die Leiharbeit gehen und den Minijobs
und wir müssen diese prekären
Arbeitsmarkt bekämpfen so dass sich die
Arbeit auch wirklich lohnt dass man
unabhängig werden kann von den
Leistungen und das finde ich ganz
zentral und wir werden mehr hören gleich
in der Debatte hier die um 9 Uhr
beginnen wird wie gesagt 90 Minuten
dauert für einen ersten Überblick wo die
Streitpunkte so liegen oder wo auch die
Knackpunkte liegen könnten kann jetzt
leider keine Zeit mehr gehabt über die
Umsetzung zu reden das soll ja in Stufen
erfolgen so offensichtlich der Stand der
Dinge im Moment erstmal die finanzielle
Erhöhung und alles weitere soll dann in
den kommenden Monaten kommen für heute
morgen vielen Dank Frau Tati und auch
Ihnen Herr Rosemann vielen Dank dass Sie
bei uns gewesen sind und schon mal einen
Einblick in diese Debatte gegeben haben
die wir gleich erleben werden vielen
dank ihnen beiden